[Musique]
le quotidien des Montréalais ressemble
parfois au parcours du combattant
et si le bonheur était à une heure une
heure et demie de Montréal c'est la boxe
s'est établie Pierre-Antoine jeune
entrepreneur qui est revenu dans sa
ville natale à Victoriaville après
quelques années dans la région
montréalaise le marché du travail m'a
évolué au fil des dernières années qui
nous permet aussi de revenir dans nos
régions natales
soit le télétravail ou dans notre école
l'acquisition d'une entreprise c'est
également ce que souhaite le jeune maire
de Victoriaville qui fait face à une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans la région
plus spécifiquement on a la filière
batterie à becancourt qui se développe
ultra rapidement donc il y aura beaucoup
de besoins en matière de main d'oeuvre
d'ailleurs depuis la pandémie la ville
accueilli plusieurs nouveaux résidents
on a doublé on est rendu à 500 personnes
par année depuis deux ans qui miquent va
Victoriaville puis on veut que ça se
poursuive la ville des bois francs fait
d'ailleurs équipe avec Drummondville a
fait d'inciter les Montréalais en
télétravail ou les jeunes familles à
venir s'y établir on a plus de 1000
postes là pour voir
une campagne publicitaire de cent mille
dollars axé a été lancé en début de
semaine faisant apparaître d'immense
panneaux un peu partout dans la
métropole ça coûte moins cher mais
travailler à Drummondville à
Victoriaville au centre du Québec ça
nous permet également d'avoir à
proximité plein d'espacements on dit
donc au montréalais qu'ils en auront
plus pour leur argent un exemple le prix
médian d'une unité familiale dans le
Grand Montréal ce détail à 600 000 $ à
Victoriaville c'est 276000 dollars
326000 dollars à Drummondville
cette jeune montréalais était établi à
Drummondville en début d'année je
pouvais
Montréal donc j'ai mon petit appart à
Drummondville proche du centre-ville
distance de marche l'impact de la
pandémie va se faire ressentir encore
longtemps à Montréal selon l'Institut de
la statistique la métropole aura une
croissance démographique plus faible
lors des 15 prochaines années et ce sont
plusieurs régions du Québec qui risque
d'en profiter ici Olivier Bourgue
Radio-Canada Victoriaville